okay [ __ ] we're back we're back let's
do that this look jobs where's like when
this was painted it was like head look
at the window we're all working things
are great now it's like one of those
graffiti world after someone gets shot
or hit by a car this mirror is really
affecting you I forget that we live in
separate realities mine's clearly better
what's up [ __ ] oh that's a YouTube dad
[ __ ] up hello sir now worth the
library trying to get some answers hey
closing in two hours okay and I did with
the microphone fishes microfiche
microfiche bare floor okay thanks a pop
let's do this [ __ ] [ __ ] [ __ ]
and [ __ ] inna [ __ ] [ __ ] and
hearts of their looks like someone left
up they open on this one it sure is my
laptop for nineteen fifty six years old
it's a experience mining construction
well drilling everything we're getting a
job when old cuz he's not really old I
mean you should have money than right
ideally it should be like guarantee it
should be guaranteed in general you
enjoy my young socialists shadowbox cute
no handouts you know he got during the
swamp not like crap one it's a charity
Barry what's charity barity had he not a
charity Verity I assume it is something
from skool skool of big 5 13 years old
alright see you like the kids not him
charity parity it was like you're
kidnapped by cult and then they were
like brainwashing you instead of some
colbrunn wash with the wavy dagger in a
magic mask that's not okay yeah go on
instead of that it was just effing pig
nightmare you were scared of it no I was
bored to death it was talking forever of
being like kind of others and like I
don't know helping old neighborhood you
engine repair that sounds nice charity
bairdi helps told mr pongco fixes
hovercraft i know that's the worst part
i was ryan charity buried in pink night
rarity
Wow do we set the cheap take the
elevator up and up so this is yeah i
think we are suppose to say what up once
applied includes their time this is a
week before dusk get beer cold up here
sure is maybe your ghost of here it goes
or something whatever he was he walked
through channel eccentric floor where or
something while carrying something
alright well that's even more impressive
so we're going to go find this guy
because he took someone and he's like so
i connect to this thing I'm going
through and that's not good I doubt
sound a lot more baddest in my head okay
it was fun
there you go so I've no idea to use it
really I can't do everything I'm sorry
what expertise have you brought to this
far hosting is my idea now your idea was
ghost hunting my name is Jude was tiny
bit of research oven because it serves
people why are you here because you're
my friend you [ __ ] uh-uh with when
beat twice here let me get to set up
here on every dumb asses in charge
okay here we go here we go
gases progress
how's that la
I think this is that okay they just
arguing with mr. one let's see ya
promise strike
ok so i guess the people shopped at
I think this is a ghost story that they
really need to go it has to be about
like murder get spotted all right man is
a sad as i said i do this is that i
think is it now [ __ ] it out it's talking
too much in this
she said the ghost thing possum jump
I think I repaired it [ __ ] jumped and
they want to work on it again I got
three clothes so let's get the [ __ ] out
of here dad's big bar the car and I'm a
licensed Beauvoir ships are and actually
start reading these things all right
next thing sorry buddy [ __ ] this one up
guys they talk about asking Greg to go
to the graveyard is this [ __ ] ahem what
is is that Miss quality oh I haven't
seen her since graduation she was always
kind of badass school district got some
that our program at all but she made it
work she was like some sort of art
teacher survivalist well I never
realized i think the apparent bits of
string in episode again thank you all
coming to the second meeting of the
possible springs poetry society you want
to stick around for this now get the
[ __ ] out of here public performance you
probably be outlawed when you ever seen
one schools remain never meant to the
old roommate she's an entire story on
herself she's Mary to Stein if so would
you like to have a conversation up here
not about we're not big into rhyming
everything we say [ __ ] out of here how
she doesn't have to rhyme that's the
stupidest thing I've ever heard Dexter
coming [ __ ] we live here right so
find out anything about your ghost yeah
that one big there was a moose to equip
the top to let a ghost not just any girl
Oh Joe I don't remember Little Joe she's
gifts minor he died in mysterious
circumstances Wow and I ride mysterious
I thought you were like afraid of this
goes like filled with dread and [ __ ] I'm
terrified ok so to mention the three
different places we can all check out at
work and stuff yet Greg and I also work
you guys skipped out on work all the
time maybe we
and like split this up share custody
viewing your ghost what police are we
talking about the graveyard I call that
one is close to not illegal clearly
going sure it's a historical society you
know you'd also break in the people
there like a paid to show it to you
anyway I went for the stork society
awesome to what I get stuck with awesome
jump all right a possible job we used
together in scraps perfect okay I need
to get home and do work this is going to
be awesome and also scared to death in
the chicken okay time to [ __ ] sleep
because I got to take that an
exploration of a good night what can I
get that quick change
ah great great great great he left
hopefully the dead end
[ __ ] this place feet again fish sticks
what is that I can't hear much
well it's just you get a weird and
weirder gives us him
what [ __ ] up dream anyone know that
one out okay okay
[Music]
[ __ ] weird
gotta be another one over here
okay good
this is [ __ ] weird
I think planners like you know you've
been here put this [ __ ] down
[Music]
pocket text on the way [ __ ] i aven't get
that thing over
the music though
now you like up
okay okay okay i'm finally betcha I'm
climbing I'm [ __ ] leg
and have that kind of ring I help pocket
[ __ ] oh the worst day ever
with the music read of you know yeah
I got a guy like I like yellow
I don't think they were meant to be less
plays on [ __ ] games at sophos long
lot talk to even I like [ __ ] Linden I
guess that's week's lab or so weeks ago
the right spot over here [ __ ] officially
the top
there we go
back yeah we got some money we got
[Music]
okay okay
[Music]
okay so we got to go explore makeup I be
a tree get a little bit second team foul
down okay it was like zoom in for a sec
that's weird Oh squarely and left you
asked Riley
right now start someone walk around half
a trace let's do this fak may take me a
breathless place down how cool also
maybe when tax consequences take the
insurance money and like a nebula but to
be a car I shall show where they caught
someone doing that oh you got a furnace
right now for me absol but also maybe I
go to jail now you have the mother
melville will suspect so we're expect on
well okay I'll do it squeeze on actually
doing okay did you want to check out the
graveyard xes do it the graveyard
[ __ ] [ __ ] I'm okay
anyways got that even fall fog conflicts
between the riches but rookie I get
really sad because it's not here
year-round and I'm looking I'm looking
[ __ ] I'm looking I check out there
whether statue how sweet I thought you
were like actually kind of afraid when I
am but like whatever so we wait here
yeah we go shows up this is dumb don't
act like this is dumb and well-loved for
the ride nobody good ghost story laptop
my head okay what's scary things are
like monumentally screwed right now you
know when a power gives a [ __ ] or
they're actively making it worse at a
spider profit oh geez I'm it like the
skeleton or something all right sorry
okay well spook off I say something and
you make it spookier all right how about
this the skeleton outside your window I
remember stranger personality would do
it's my leg and he's from the back come
on he's he would tell you they're gonna
take your house this is just depressing
and he's a zombie I can't find my work
zombie back at all the things you're
afraid of her boring scary stuff is like
really really boring oh my god Lee truth
what were we supposed to be done
watching a statue or something that lets
go
re witness a murder what's going on here
okay so I'm gonna go visit my mom she's
right down there okay Gary minute to
okay totally no problem sorry sorry
about what i bet your mom and all today
it happens coo coo coo i'll check out
some grapes already I took class on
death and dying when I couldn't get it
to dinosaur clawed back to school it's
like something actually know about
college back you it I thought she won a
minute
the [ __ ]
I cancer choice but the [ __ ] talker
hey is this yep
it's out there daddy honey I'm gonna see
some [ __ ] with who's not around
pick up there
nothing crab takes a little bit later
Wow
taken by the flow for traitors all this
[ __ ] fat I was like 14 years
time probably never stood a anything
anyone to understand you should get off
at least one time it was life
where the story
the heck
Fanson throw the fantasy guy okay when I
guess you hit my bike and they engraved
his murderers comes down forever shape
that's cuz he of the traces up there
hopefully she got killing myself what is
she [ __ ] caliber so he's clock bell
hey got a gal fine she's still there
were you worried about that you know how
good having a single problems with town
now that would signal problems with town
and that's what's wrong with your street
just cause your work on your street
anyway I was buried in pretty low spot
couldn't afford the hill so I was
worried like you're worried the ground
was going to give it what part of sicko
disposed to understand where the
graveyard that shouldn't make those
wrinkles or problems you should have
built talents on flood and yet here we
are okay you ready now when I was down
there I think I heard losing something
he'll hit like voices it's a spooky yeah
naturally so not fair go find out
you get this all right
what are we looking at
put the top of the hill
but I wonder our way this is a [ __ ]
worst thing I've ever seen
all right you guys like my cat shirt is
a cat it's a kidding for Meg now I can
look at Ozma's so dope oh here we go
this oh why you let me go for now chef
[ __ ] be [ __ ] and such as the
kitchen what the [ __ ] is this o weary
travelers you seek answers along the
dead but they shall give you not the
[ __ ] are you more messengers observe
remember hey if there were teens
yeah well we had two keepers of the game
and a little gate you're sitting in
front of we got one who shall pass and
inhale away all right well Aunt Ruth
used to question truthfully what and he
might pass the realm with that okay
whatever first question have you ever
done it you just call it sex or
grown-ups here answer yeah it was
fantastic really no I'm very much lying
okay and yeah yeah one wet summer for
love with grace really how did I not
notice when you are talking away their d
happens with the heat on I'm was a mad
kid math camp what is that if you go and
do math stuff camp stuff what the [ __ ]
skyway dream date
tall dressed cool who is smart like the
music and you go to move it wrestling
they can wrestle again next question is
that question what does she want some
Berenson experience what just count what
time forward in front of class
once I'm in high school it was awkward i
had to wear a dress and I couldn't slow
down but he was really nice stuff I
guess I'm tried to kiss them by some
much screwed it up into your blood he
bit him have been divested kiss I've no
idea what he was bleeding a lot the rest
of the bathroom I'm showing spirit house
to his my own and I overdo it he starts
choking and like fighting back and I'm
like chowing down que me AMA still don't
know tables to shove them down my dress
and I'm like plowing through these
almonds and one gets caught my throat
poor cole slips against the bathroom
wall I should give myself a holic
groomer and it works but I puke all over
cold chicken cordon bleu right dad son
walks in and sees cold days of bleeding
and choking and be puking into the sink
so I pull off the paper towels his mouth
some reason I think of flushing down the
toilet and I masseur flow so I grab cold
pulled my the bathroom but it was
covered puking blood into a little water
and he ran away and left and he was my
ride oh [ __ ] i was gonna [ __ ] up how
seriously myself man i think i said i
want to wait I'm gonna have nightmares
about it k past now yeah no it's good
topic to face the face of o Smaug a
passing bird burden thank you
ok
the [ __ ] was that about so let go go
yeah I don't know if I believe in them
but ya know you said you could see it go
tonight I mean I'm not super into so
much to you but obviously it's just
dreams okay that's certainly are taken
but like did you ever see my mom no I
mean I can't really tell and I'll take
the ghost or like people like they're
sitting around because it's more like
exes that goes whoosh if it happened in
people that were here just we know the
places look super small but your mom was
right as hell two rides a hack there
that's like I appreciate you try to turn
around when do I best Patrice all right
anyway so the bad news is that we're
locked out by that big ice skate I'm
going to try and get in the graveyard to
keep people like you out and stop what
you're probably going to do and then
we're never sure all right well not
Klima is using my thing you give this
kind of thing before some [ __ ]
alright so I obviously have to go up
these things and lock it from the side
okay I gotta get the tree to break down
onto there we go I shouldn't we saw that
we're going to get sued something else
back here is getting late back hurts
they go to Little Joe's grave
there's little chose gray
what
joe says this is have ground here as
well swap it grow so what do we do here
and I guess we still look around for go
don't make this a thing I think it's
cool may i'm here for you right now
started yet a town town stout thank you
and I checked
good [ __ ] here did what am i doing all
right [ __ ] here just stupid something it
just stupid it pop by the ground or
anything this is stupid i'm going to
smash it so dude hold up wakey wakey
Little Joe then it's on right oh [ __ ]
holy [ __ ] holy [ __ ] what do you do
you're right I didn't tell you to do
that about the sinkhole lucky it wasn't
deeper well wait is that yeah it's a
coffee oh crap so we're going to open it
right no we're not going to open a
coffee with a rotting corpse in it that
it's been a long time he's not rotting
any more cheese we're not doing this are
you kind of curious at least yeah okay
let's do it oh this [ __ ] up okay I'm
third one two three
one stop [ __ ] yeah top like we're at
tech this one out with like limo vandals
chef what two silver back there watching
us oh god I don't know where they went
just like Abba the corner of my eye is
that I don't know but we need to leave
now it could really go now we're gone
now ok let's go no it's just a lollipop
oh [ __ ] there's a pretty [ __ ] eight
the killer that was weird yeah weird
that's crime you should go through their
email that goes to do ok finally she was
there maybe was crammed keeper Sullivan
rusticating whose renew his grave dress
hey the crepes guy he was dude oh shut
up so that's one goes we saw someone
whatever we're leaving for the cops get
here
that's [ __ ] up time to go to fat
[ __ ] pad for some world where dreams
come on just for wicked more now don't
leave a sweet dreams yet
and I'm [ __ ] go am I am
[Music]
that's my success
put the pot but which ones are so pretty
what the [ __ ]
hello
can you talk yep for some reason to the
first thing here I thought to talk to
are you god no
texaco little creatures are coming and
they're asking if i am god and i am
asking what God is and they are telling
me and I'm not this God and this God is
nowhere well that's where faith comes in
i guess little creatures are explaining
faith and moments ago is the beginning
and i'm here that in here now and
there's nowhere for God to be hiding so
what am I doing here monstrous existence
I mean what are we doing here what are
you one of those giant animals have I
been seeing ghosts they're like bits of
the world i think i was on a training
but i was like a town it's all I lost it
okay so a great piece was walking
through the sams and they're climbing
into the air and now they're making a
tear and now they are gone and now you
are here but the little creatures are
wandering through the air and they are
dragging in places and echoes of live
and they're asking me that God my head
hurt I'm going to tell you something
little creature you're suing further and
further out to sea beyond I think slide
and terrible and I'm showing you
the [ __ ] is ever like the texting
yeah I guess they're blind but they're
saying him and you're telling to them
after this you are not returning here
I'm coming into the air and closing the
sky I've type of speaking of little
creatures I'm type of speaking of God I
will tell you a second thing there is a
whole center of everything and it is
always growing between the stars and I
am seeing it is coming and you were now
escaping needing worships forgetting me
when the universe is being forgotten and
there is nothing to remember it's not
even the things beyond and now there was
only the whole
how to learn about trees in the fall
what about the leaves there exists some
screaming nothing you are atoms and your
Adam's not caring if your existing your
atoms are monstrous existence then want
me here why which doesn't feel wires
going little creature you are not chosen
there is no one to choose you is going
nowhere we're not meeting again and the
University of forgetting you and I
remembering you but I'm not because I'm
caring beginning his moments ago deniz
lit the way there was no time to forget
before I was forgotten goodbye little
creature
[Music]
will call their folks thanks for
watching dang yep